ce soir on vous emmène d'abord à Toronto
ou des chercheurs ont réussi à doubler
le nombre d'organes disponibles pour des
transplantations
[Musique]
ce matin à Toronto une vie s'est arrêtée
la victime a posé son dernier geste de
solidarité
elle a donné ses organes dans l'espoir
de sauver d'autres vies
ses poumons en temps normal auraient été
refusé ils sont en mauvais état mais
dans quelques heures ils seront
transplantés à un patient qui les
attendent désespérément
à l'hôpital général de Toronto c'est
qu'on arrive à réparer des organes
nous sommes nombreux à consentir à
donner nos organes en cas de décès
mais très peu d'entre nous deviendront
d'honneur seulement 1% des personnes qui
meurent dans un hôpital répondent aux
critères pour le don d'organe
il y a parfois du gaspillage
à peine 20% des poumons prélevés chez
les donneurs d'organes sont utilisés
le chirurgien chef et chef J est un
pionnier de la greffe du poumon
il a assisté à la toute première double
transplantation pulmonaire c'était à
Toronto en 1986
depuis il a consacré sa vie à augmenter
le nombre de poumons disponibles pour
ses patients en attente d'une greffe on
a doublé le nombre d'organes qu'on peut
transplanter et on a tracé la voie pour
le monde entier
les poumons arrivés ce matin à l'hôpital
général de Toronto sont noircis
le donneur était probablement fumeur ou
habitait en pleine ville
mais ce n'est pas ce qui inquiète
l'équipe de chirurgien
certaines parties ne se gonflent pas
normalement
le donneur avait peut-être une infection
les médecins vont examiner les poumons
et tenter de les réparer la clé c'est
conserver les poumons à l'extérieur du
corps humain suffisamment longtemps pour
faire le travail
chaque chef J a inventé une machine
expressément à cette fin
qu'on pourrait ouvrir et fermer on s'est
inspiré du stade skydom de Toronto
le dôme assure au poumons de rester en
milieu stérile à l'abri des infections
le reste de la quincaillerie remplace le
corps humain en quelque sorte
une pompe joue le rôle du coeur elle
fait circuler une solution nutritive qui
remplace le sang la solution est
chauffée à 37 degrés Celsius la
température du corps humain
l'inhalation et l'expiration sont
assurés par un respirateur artificiel
sur une table je n'aurais jamais pu
imaginer ça quand j'étais étudiant
c'était de la science-fiction
pendant que les poumons sont superfusion
l'équipe les passe au rayon X
avant il fallait deviner et on aurait
probablement pas utilisé ce poumon
elle prélève des tissus pour faire une
biopsie
et l'analyse aussi le liquide à la
sortie des poumons
il faut poser un diagnostic rapidement
et trouver un plan de traitement
spécifique à chaque poumon
les nutriments ou des médicaments
ajoutés au liquides de perfusion peuvent
renverser certains dommages
le système de perfusion ex-vivaux donne
accès à une toute nouvelle catégorie de
donneurs d'organes
c'est la première cause de mortalité en
Occident
même pas les organes de ces personnes
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à les prélever
avant qu'il soit trop endommagés
avec nos nouvelles stratégies on peut
maintenant les remettre en état et les
transplanter
les poumons placés dans le système
ex-vivaux peuvent être maintenues en vie
12 à 18h avant d'être transplanté cela
donne le temps aux chirurgien de mieux
planifier la transplantation
des équipes médicales n'ont plus besoin
d'opérer en urgence durant la nuit
dans des laboratoires situés à quelques
pas de l'hôpital on va encore plus loin
on a réussi à maintenir des poumons de
porc dans le système XIV
le chirurgien Marcus sipel et la colite
du docteur chefgi c'est lui qui a mené
cette expérience
lorsqu'on arrivera à 5 ou 6 jours on
pourra peut-être avoir des organes en
réserveur compatible
plusieurs autres expériences sont en
cours pour tester la médecine du futur
les chercheurs arrivent à éliminer
certains virus des poumons comme celui
de l'hépatite C
ou un virus peu connu mais très répandu
nommé CMV pour cytomégalovirus
la majorité d'entre nous sommes porteurs
de ce virus sans même le savoir il est
en dormance dans nos cellules
lorsqu'un organe contaminé se retrouve
dans le corps d'un receveur le virus se
réveille
c'est le virus qui cause le plus de
problèmes à nos patients immunodéprimés
dans une autre expérience les chercheurs
ont réussi à changer le groupe sanguin
d'un poumon oui
on a converti des poumons du groupe A au
groupe O en seulement 3 ou 4 heures de
traitement
les patients du groupe sanguin O
attendent en moyenne deux fois plus
longtemps pour recevoir un poumon
comparativement à ceux du groupe A
ils ont 20% plus de risques de mourir
avant de recevoir une greffe
les scientifiques ont utilisé une enzyme
pour éliminer la presque totalité des
molécules responsables du groupe sanguin
fonctionné
[Musique]
d'un groupe sanguin différent il n'y a
eu aucun signe de rejet pendant les
heures qui ont suivi
le rêve ultime de chef et chef J est
encore plus ambitieux
il veut modifier génétiquement les
organes pour les rendre 100% compatible
avec les receveurs
on organe n'a pas été conçu pour être
extrait d'un corps expédié à l'autre
bout du pays et placer dans le corps
d'un autre le corps humain est conçu
pour reconnaître qu'il s'agit d'un
intrus et le rejeter dès qu'on
transplantent un organe le corps du
receveur commence à le détruire mais
pourrait-on transformer l'organe pour
tromper le corps du receveur de façon à
ce qu'il croit que cet organe lui
appartient
son équipe a mené les premières
expériences sur des organes animaux
les chercheurs ont ajouté à des poumons
un gène responsable de la fabrication
d'une protéine appelée im10 cette
protéine a un effet anti-inflammatoire
dans les poumons qui ont subi un
traumatisme à la suite d'une greffe elle
réduit les risques de rejet
en 2022 l'équipe de chefs J a reçu 24
millions de dollars du gouvernement du
Canada pour étendre ses recherches à
d'autres organes
les essais sont en cours sur des fois et
des reins
ici le chirurgien Hanane Ghana tente de
dégraisser des fois
avec le taux d'obésité qui augmente il y
a de plus en plus de donneurs qui ont
des fois trop gras
pas parce qu'on craint qu'il ne
survivent pas à la greffe
sous perfusion un foie va graduellement
éliminer le gras
le défi c'est d'arriver à le maintenir
hors du corps suffisamment longtemps
dans un montage juste à côté on mène des
expériences avec un rein
ici aussi le maintien de l'organe ex
vivo pourrait révolutionner la vie du
receveur
il n'est pas rare qu'un rein fraîchement
transplanté mais plusieurs jours avant
de fonctionner correctement
durant tout ce temps le patient doit
être gardé à l'hôpital sous dialyse
on pense qu'on pourrait lui donner un
coup de fouet et réduire le temps de
latence après la transplantation
[Musique]
des chirurgiens viennent de partout pour
apprendre à utiliser le système de
perfusion des poumons mise au point à
Toronto
plusieurs centres hospitaliers dont le
CHUM à Montréal sont équipés de la
technologie
mais aucun ne rivalise avec les
performances de l'équipe torontoise soit
par manque d'expérience ou de personnel
chef et chef J et Marcelo CIPEL planche
sur une nouvelle génération d'appareils
d'utilisation et plus intuitive
j'ai dit aux ingénieurs que ça devrait
être comme un micro-ondes on appuie sur
la touche pop-corn et voilà on obtient
du pop-corn ça devrait être aussi simple
que ça
les chercheurs veulent y ajouter une
forme d'intelligence artificielle pour
guider l'équipe médicale
un algorithme peut nous dire qu'un
poumon est viable et que le receveur à
90% de chances d'être sorti des soins
intensifs dans trois jours
rien ne semble arrêter les ambitions des
chirurgiens
ils entrouvoient le jour où des organes
usagés seront disponibles à volonté et
attendront sur des tablettes
en ce moment il y a des patients qu'on
ne met même pas sur la liste d'attente
parce qu'il risque de mourir avant
d'obtenir un organe
où il n'y aura plus de liste d'attente
quand on a conçu ce système personne n'y
croyait les experts en transplantation
disait que ça n'allait jamais
fonctionner on leur a prouvé le
contraire